Let's just do it because our
brain
Thoughts are starting get antsy and their talking us out of this idea in negative ways
Which is what this video is all about
Hi, my name is Grace Hel....
Wow, fucking nailing it. Hi. My name is Grace Helbig, if you did not know. Now, you know your life is different now.
This has been a weird year for me
This also is probably gonna be a very rambling a little all over the place video and that's it
So you can accept that or bye. I want to sit down and just sort of talk openly
stream of conscious esque
style
About the year I've had because it's been wonky to say the least
There's been really wonderful beautiful moments. And this is the time of the morning when goose decides to bark because she's just been sleeping
The whole time that had the camera off, but when the camera goes on now
It's a like mother like dog-htre - that's a really wonderful moments. This year are some really beautiful
Joyous things and then I've had some really dark and sad and frustrating things this year
it's just been uh, I guess a transitional year so they wanted to sit down and talk about it with you guys because I think
That's also what people do
That helps is they talk about it. Not necessarily on camera. I mean like I'm the therapist knows all this but like, you know,
She doesn't hit like like and subscribe after a session. That would be
fascinating and probably
unhealthy I wanted to talk about with you guys because there has been a little disconnect because I felt disconnected from the internet all
Year, and I wanted to just feel a little bit more like a human to you guys rather than so
presentational about cooking or
You know favorites videos or other
Nonsense everyone, I feel nervous saying all of this stuff. I think it's because I
Don't put a lot of like my personal thoughts and feelings out in such a direct way
But I think this is something a lot of creators
Go through and a lot of people that aren't creators go through it is the idea of feeling
stuck of feeling in a rut of developing a lot of negative self-talk that
stifles your creativity stifles your ability to have
meaningful relationships stifles your ability to
Just go to a grocery store and buy groceries sometimes for those of you
I'm watching me forever know that I've dealt with eating disorder
I've dealt with anxiety depression and anxiety depression have gotten a big hold of me this year
Which is crazy because I'm in like the most wonderful
relationship ever, but then my creative world feels very
Overwhelmed with a lot of anxiety and negative self-talk this year, which has kept me from
Creating kind of talked about this last year a little bit and I think I thought by talking about it
it might help facilitate some sort of motivation and you know what that didn't happen and I have
finally come to terms with the fact that you can't just go to bed and
like hope
That the next morning all the sudden you wake up and all the lightbulbs are turned on and you're ready to go
And yeah, you're back in the strides that you used to have. I've gotten into a big rut of
comparing myself to my former self of going
Oh, man
2012 to 2014/2015 were the prime years and I could just get back to what that felt like
Then we'd be back on track baby turns out that doesn't happen or work or is good
It's very akin to when like retired football players just drink heavily and re-watch their old
Games to just feel like they were once good at something
Much like that and that's sad and dark and depressing but it's kind of true
gotten myself into this hamster wheel routine this year of
Comparing myself to previous times and feeling like I'm not living up to that
Level and talking myself down from things out of things that I'm not good enough through things that like the funny
Thing that I had going is gone like that was a fluke and like all of these irrational
things that have made me feel very
Weighed down. It's like I tied a bunch of bricks on to my feet and I'm
Still going but I can swim across that river watch this. Nope
No, I can't I couldn't even swim across that river if I didn't have any bricks on
I'm not a good swimmer helbig's are not a swimming family when I was younger
I did like two small triathlons with my younger brother and my dad
in like our home town and
We are all three almost drown and the swimming was the first part of the entire triathlon. We made the teenage lifeguards very nervous
The cool thing is I've been going to therapy consistently which highly recommend if you can do it. Very cool
That's huge for me because I don't like talking to people about my feelings
Especially - I don't like going back week after week. I like to do it once and go
well
I did that scary thing
That I didn't think I could do and I have to do it again and again and again and again to get the results
It's not just a one and done. I can't just fall asleep and wake up then all the lights are on
Okay, so I've been really proud of myself for going and doing the therapy thing. It's been very helpful
This is where I go. Maybe I should have written down my thoughts
before I started this video to try and make this a little bit more cohesive, but then when you say should to yourself
That's a negative way of talking to yourself. So I'm doing just fine right now. This is great
It's all gonna work out fine. It is working out fine. We're in the present moment right here
I've really realized how much negative self-talk I've given myself in the last couple of months and it's become this real heavy
routine that I feel like I finally am ready to curiously
Investigate just at the end of the year and as we get into the new year
Everyone's doing their whole self evaluations and figuring out what ways they want to live their lives in 2020
Also, I think 2019 was a weird year for all of us
Let me know if it was weird for you so that I can feel not alone here because I would love that
What am I getting at baby yoda was exactly what I needed at the end of this year
And I don't even if the mandalorian is getting boring. I don't understand plots of shows at all whatsoever
Anyway, I'm just waiting for that baby Yoda to show up. Oh, there's got to be bars out there that have BYOB
why bring your own baby Yoda, I
don't know why I don't know why you would show up to a bar with like a
stuffed animal baby Yoda
But I don't know why you wouldn't either
I also it felt a little bit like I
Took a step back last year and in that period I really distanced myself from the YouTube space
Almost in a way that when someone takes a break in between
high school and college they take a year off and then they try to go back to college and
Everything is different and nothing makes sense. I mean to be fair even when I was doing YouTube like really
Pounding that YouTube space. I didn't fully understand what was going on on the platform
I was just like here's a new funny thing
here's a new funny, here's a new funny thing and they'd be like
How do you think we can make the platform better?
Like I don't even it's a shock that I even know how to upload a video
so you're asking the wrong girl and now it's like
It's very intimidating
It's a very intimidating space now because it's very different than what it used to be
I'm a little bit in a space of I don't know what I want to do and I feel very
impatient about not knowing and I want to just know and work and do the next thing I have to give myself some space to
Work on my brain house this year faired for you guys. Anyone else feeling similar things also
I don't know if you guys experienced like when there's really great stuff happening in your life
There's a guilt for feeling even slightly anxious or bad or negative about other stuff in your life
She's like but this is so good. And there's also a lot of people that would kill for this situation. So, how could you even
Whine or complain or cry about this situation, I'm not to feel all the feelings
Because I'm not a robot. Hey
in the future
I feel like an AI robot is gonna re-watch that clip out of context and they're gonna come for me and murder me if they
Haven't murdered our entire human race already other thoughts I think about so I have a hard time expressing gratitude
I've heard - expressing feelings, especially on the Internet and the public forum
I wanted to say thank you to everyone that's been watching the videos for years you guys can tell
If I'm off even if I try to hide it and mask it y'all know you all it's pretty transparent
It's funny how sometimes your most transparent when you're trying to hide a lot of
You probably know this but I'm obsessed with Michael Buckley because on his Instagram stories. He he's a life coach now
He's OG youtuber if you don't know then hello welcome. You probably a ninth grader and
My videos aren't for children
So don't Coppa me Michael Buckley is now a life coach and his Instagram story is just so wonderful to me
I've been watching it since the beginning of the year and he bounced these like very
wonderful seeds of wisdom
here and there and then he'll show you about like his new sweater that I got and how much he loves her hates it and
Him at a piano bar and then him talking about his adult soccer
It's all wonderful hodgepodge, but the stuff that he was saying even this morning
it felt very pointed and I got scared to even sit down and do this video even after I decided that I was going to
Then all the negative talk is like hey guess well
Oh, yeah, we're ready to do our job, which is talk you out of it
I watched his Instagram story and it you just talked about how comparing yourself to your former self is
So detrimental that you are exactly where you need to be right now
And you decide how you show up and everything is happening as it should right now
I highly recommend for you guys to go watch Michael Buckley story because it's just so
pleasant and I never know what I'm gonna get and it's uh
Like you said, true delight I'm gonna talk about audible in this
Episode because they've sponsored this video and I'm thankful for that
companies that I've been working with this year that have sponsored videos because one of their genuine companies that I really love and I love
Working with things that I can show you that I actually use on a regular basis and - they're probably the reason that I made
Any videos this year if I didn't have an obligation
for an ad
Situation. I probably would have sat in blankets and watch reality TV
So I'm thankful
that they've even tried to support me enough to get me motivated to make content this year because I do like making content once I
get through all of the
forrest
of why the fuck are you doing this? It's really wonderful that audible sponsoring this video because I just started listening to
to UnFuck Yourself by Gary John Bishop
It's so perfect for the stuff that's going on in my brain and world right now
I'm only thirty minutes into it and I'm obsessed with it. He's a Scottish guy. That is
Incredible it's basically like tough love self-help. It's like if you have like an older Scottish brother or dad that like loved you
But wasn't gonna coddle you like and that's exactly the kind of self-help stuff that I respond to
It's like no bullshit and it's straight to the point. He basically says in the first 30 minutes
I'm not gonna teach you how to do mantras
I'm not gonna tell you to say that you're lion because you're not a fucking lion and second of all
You're not a fucking lion. I did an air kick when I heard that. It's all about negative self-talk and it's all about
How we can approach that
I'm just so excited
To listen to this that it might take me a second to edit this video because I might just fall down a wormhole of listening
To the rest of this if you want to give yourself an audible
membership now is the time or gift an audible membership now is the time because you can get an audible membership for
53% off you can choose three titles every month an audiobook and two exclusive audible originals
You can listen on any device anytime anywhere with the audible app
it's super easy and like I said right now for a limited time you can get your first 3 months for
$6.95 per month 53 percent off the original price three months
$6.95 per month if you visit audible.com/grace or you text Grace to 500 - 500
obviously my recommendation is I'm yourself by Gary John Bishop if you really want some of that like
Scottish punch things Scottish punch is just called like
Scotch, right
They have a billion categories so you can choose from different books and an audible original is the self-help category is obviously very popular
Right now the end of 2019 into 2020 2020 is gonna be a kick-ass year for so many things
I feel it in my bones
Which is why I think I'm bold enough to sit down and have this kind of conversation with you something
I would never have done years ago. I also am
Getting what humans call older so I am giving less
I also want to be more of a person to you and not so presentational because that's more in line with how I'm
In my life right now the great things that have happened this year
Obviously mamrie and I have our podcast this might get weird that you can listen to every Wednesday
Which has been so awesome we have a patreon for it. That's been really great
And we had a lot of excitement going into 2020 making that work and also not too deep
It's been really cool
If you guys have listened to that podcast
You can tell that I'm having more in-depth conversations with humans that I never thought
I'd have a chance to sit down and talk to and so that's where my brain is at a little bit more
It's less away from the gag jokes and more into just like being a human and also
maybe I'll just cringe after editing this video and
Throw all of my devices into the nearest water source
I don't want to predict the future. I want to live in the present. It's a gift
I know I'm gonna turn this camera off and have
10,000 more articulate thoughts about what I wanted to say, but that's me thinking negatively. This went great. I did great
Thank you guys for listening to this very rambley. Just sort of mental health update
It's been a wonky year, but it feels nice admitting that it's also very cool to start making active choices
to
switch the way that this
Current situation is I hope you guys have had as best a year as you could we're all doing it
We did. Well we almost did it. There's still time for shit to hit so many fans
There is so much time for fecal matter to hit wind sources if you like this video give it a thumbs up.
Don't forget to subscribe, especially if you're my therapist. Again, thanks guys.
I Don't know